good morning john so at this point it's
pretty easy to not know what to think
and maybe there's a little bit of like
internet sociology mechanics to that
like
people will say here's a good idea and
then very soon afterwards there will be
another
sort of movement of no that's a bad idea
followed of course by me and the rest of
the world throwing up our hands and
saying well i guess
we'll never know there's also something
really normal about this because of
course we
won't ever know like when it comes to
big hard problems
we're never like even if we solve them
really successfully we won't have solved
them in the best
possible way there's just too many ways
to do it but the thing that grinds my
gears about all this
is how devoid of data and analysis these
conversations tend to be they tend to
focus
mostly on how the arguments make people
feel which i get
this is how rhetoric works but it's nice
to have data to support what you're
saying i'm being too abstract here and i
don't need to be so
we have known for the entire 41 years of
my existence that
climate change is going to impose some
pretty devastating instability on our
world and yes there are still people
who through greed or bias or ignorance
don't think that that's a thing
but we know they're wrong what we don't
know though is what exactly to do about
it
on a personal level i don't know what i
should do about it more complicatedly i
don't know what you should do about it
and if we're being honest with ourselves
none of us know what we would do if we
were the only person in the world with
power
to decrease the impacts of climate
change in such a way that it would
have the least amount of negative
impacts on existing people
and have the most positive impact on
people of the future but let's just
stick to ourselves there have been some
conversations about like what people
should do individually to interface with
the climate crisis and we've probably
all seen
that thing going around that's like it
doesn't matter what individuals do
because 90 of the emissions are done by
50 companies or something like that
which
is a nonsense thought right because like
if those companies
just closed up shop and none of them
ever did anything again
billions of people would die like you do
still have to put gasoline into the
truck that brings the food to the store
like like at least that and and also the
tractors and also the
energy used to heat and cool homes so
that you don't die so that you you get
it you get that so that's a fun
sticky idea that resolves anyone of
their personal responsibility
it feels good it resonates with people
it doesn't make any sense but there is a
more compelling version of this idea
that goes something like
look we got to give up on this personal
responsibility stuff because
this needs to not be individual
solutions it needs to be system-wide
solutions and focusing on individuals
is distracting us from putting pressure
on governments and corporations to make
the actual changes that will have actual
impacts and that idea
i would guess really resonates with you
it really resonates with me it's
logically consistent it makes a lot of
sense i have no idea if it's true though
and research shows that it's not it
turns out one of the most important ways
that we show that something is an
emergency
is by acting like it's an emergency if
we are not actually acting like there is
a problem
our brains have a hard time remembering
that there is a problem and also the
people around us have fewer
opportunities
to see that there are people acting as
if there is a crisis
social scientists have studied this and
they found that people taking individual
action
leads to more pushes for policy change
not less the original idea is that if
you focus more on individual action
there will be less push for policy
change
it turns out to be the opposite of that
as social psychologists leore hackl and
greg sparkman said in their 2018 article
people don't spring into action because
they see smoke they spring into action
because they see others rushing in with
water so taking action has effects on
people around you
it also has effects on you it emphasizes
within an individual that these things
matter what science is showing
is that taking individual action never
results in people being more lenient on
systems
it does the opposite it empowers the
people taking the action
and their neighbors to push for more
systemic change so the good news is
we do have hard-working people doing
research
to tell us whether or not the things
that we read on the internet are wrong
the bad news
is that if the tweet makes us feel good
we don't tend to spend a lot of time
doing a bunch of research to tell us
whether or not it actually
is good john i'll see you on tuesday